The things that make the Punisher so unique
and polarizing go beyond the way he deals with
criminals. From the influences that led to his
creation to the strange evolution on the page,
here's the in-depth, untold
truth behind the Punisher.
There are very few comic book characters whose
creation hasn't been influenced by something else.
The Punisher was no exception. Before
Frank Castle hit the comics page in 1974,
there was Mack Bolan: The Executioner.
Created by Don Pendleton in 1969,
The Executioner was a series of pulpy adventure
novels that were incredibly successful.
As for what they were about, well, see if
any of this sounds familiar. Mack Bolan was
a highly decorated Green Beret whose service
in the Vietnam War earned him an evocative
nickname. Unfortunately, his action as a soldier
couldn't keep him from experiencing tragedy on the
home front. His family was killed in a gruesome
crime that turned out to be tied to the Mafia,
prompting Bolan to go AWOL and launch
a one-man war against organized crime.
A few years after Pendleton created The
Executioner, The Punisher appeared in 1974's
Amazing Spider-Man #129. The version who appears
there is a bit different from how he'd evolve over
the next decade, but you can see the groundwork
in the original story. Despite being a hired
assassin working for the supervillain the Jackal,
he claimed to only kill those who "deserved" it,
and was only targeting Spider-Man because he'd
been tricked into believing that Spidey was
a killer. He also mentions that he's a former
Marine, but now fights, quote, "a lonely war."
Originally, the Punisher was conceived as a
straight-up villain. In the course of writing
the issue, however, Conway realized that,
quote, "he had a moral code I could use to
resolve story points." As a result, the Punisher
simply walked away at the end of the story,
with Spider-Man getting out of the whole
"attempted murder" thing pretty quickly.
While he wouldn't get his own comic for
another ten years after his initial appearance,
it wasn't long before the Punisher started
headlining stories of his own. Mostly,
this happened in the pages of magazines like
Marvel Preview, which were printed without the
approval of the Comics Code Authority, and lent
themselves to more violent, adult-oriented tales.
All of that changed in January of 1986 and the
release of The Punisher #1. Titled "Circle of
Blood," it picked up with Frank being sent to
prison at Ryker's Island, which, as you may know,
is a very large building containing nothing
but people who hate the Punisher. It followed
Frank as he was broken out by the Trust, a
clandestine organization that wanted to fund
him in his war against crime and spark a gang war
that would take out most of Manhattan's criminals.
The five-issue miniseries was a success, and
1987 saw the launch of a Punisher series that
would run for over a hundred issues and cement
Frank Castle as one of Marvel's top characters.
The Punisher ongoing series was
still definitely a Marvel title,
but the focus was rarely on supervillains.
Instead, much like it had in the beginning,
the Punisher's solo adventures drew
their influences from outside comics.
That's a nice way of saying that writer Mike Baron
spent a few years basically rewriting the action
movie aisle of a Blockbuster as 22-page comics.
The most egregious example comes pretty early on.
In Punisher #14, Frank goes undercover as a
substitute teacher to root out a drug dealing
operation at a high school, an adventure that
bears some striking similarities to Class of 1984,
a film that's basically just "what if the guy
from Death Wish was a high school teacher?"
To Baron's credit, though, the story where
Frank goes undercover with a biker gang to
topple their meth empire actually
predates the release of Stone Cold,
a cinematic flop starring ex-football player Brian
Bosworth with the exact same plot, by over a year.
Frank Castle kills his enemies. It's the thing
that sets him apart from the other characters
in the Marvel Universe, and to a larger
extent, superheroes as a whole. There is,
however, a problem with that, at least from a
storytelling standpoint: if you kill your enemies,
they can never be developed into compelling
nemeses. If you get right down to it, that's
the real world reason that Batman doesn't kill the
Joker. He's just too popular to go away forever.
"I think you and I are
destined to do this forever."
That extends into another problem, in that
it limits the scope of Frank's enemies to
characters he can actually kill. The Punisher's
arch-enemy for the first year of his solo
title was the Kingpin, and that story never
resolves for the simple reason that it can't.
The Kingpin is too big a character to be killed
off by a guy who primarily fights regular human
criminals. Put those traits together and the end
result is that the Punisher, by his very nature,
doesn't have many villains who
survive their first appearances.
There are a few exceptions to the Punisher's
tendency to kill off the bad guys,
and the biggest is Jigsaw. After originally
appearing in Amazing Spider-Man #162, with a
shadowy cameo in the previous issue, Jigsaw would
return as a bullet in Frank's side for years.
Jigsaw was built around a pretty simple
concept: in his early days as a vigilante,
Frank chucked a guy named Billy Russo
headfirst through a plate glass window.
Billy's formerly handsome face was shredded by
the shards of glass, and after it was stitched
up into a form that closely resembled a
jigsaw puzzle, he was out for revenge.
The thing is, none of that really happens in
his first appearance — possibly because it
was a little too violent for 1976. Instead, when
Jigsaw first appears, all that stuff is backstory,
with the understanding that Frank has been around
for a while doing terrible things to criminals.
As for Jigsaw, there's something of a recurring
gag about how he'll get his face fixed,
only to have it messed up again by the end
of the story. The strangest example of this
might be the time that his face was healed by
a mystically powerful villain named Lucifer,
who claimed to be the actual Devil
himself. That lasted about 15
pages before Frank repeatedly
rammed Jigsaw's face into a cactus.
As the closest thing Frank has to a long-term
arch-nemesis in the comics, it's not surprising
that Jigsaw has made it into most adaptations of
the Punisher, including the Netflix show. This
version of the character had a very different
origin. Rather than just being some two-bit
mobster, Billy Russo was an old friend of Frank's
that he'd served alongside in the Marines — which
also made him one of the soldiers who'd killed an
innocent man who was framed for being a terrorist.
To keep his secret, Russo tried to kill Frank,
but you already know how well that works out
for the bad guys. At the end of season 1, Frank
repeatedly smashed Billy's face into a mirror.
Considering how violent the Netflix
shows can get, it's a bit surprising
that Billy's scars aren't quite as grotesque
as his comic book counterpart's. Instead,
Netflix's Jigsaw developed a fascination with the
masks he wore while recovering from his injuries,
decorating them to be creepy, disfigured
skulls due to his nightmares about Frank.
He did share the original's desire for
revenge, though, and his success rate.
By the end of the '80s, the Punisher
was well on his way to becoming one
of the most popular characters
in Marvel's catalogue of heroes.
He also had one advantage that Spider-Man and
the X-Men didn't: he didn't have the kind of
superpowers that would require a massive
special effects budget to bring to film.
As a result, the 1989 Punisher movie, in
which Dolph Lundgren starred as Frank Castle,
probably seemed like a safe bet for
low-budget success. It was not. The film
was never theatrically released in America
and wouldn't hit home video until 1991.
Looking back from 30 years later, however, The
Punisher '89 has its share of flaws, but it's also
a pretty faithful adaptation. The plot is lifted
from the first year of Punisher solo comics,
where Frank's war against the mob has caused
them to seek an uneasy alliance with the Yakuza.
The origin was changed to make Frank a cop rather
than a soldier, distancing him from Vietnam,
but that's also a tactic that different comic
book versions of the character have used.
It's no exaggeration to
say that by the early '90s,
the Punisher was one of Marvel's most
popular characters. If you need proof,
look no further than the sheer amount of comics
about the character that were being published.
While the Punisher was starring in three titles
every month, characters like Captain America, Iron
Man, and Thor all had... one apiece. The Avengers
had their regular title and Avengers West Coast.
The only other characters on or above Frank's
level at the time were Spider-Man, with four,
and the all-consuming, unstoppable steamroller
that was the X-Men, which topped out somewhere
around nine or ten, if you count everything that
had a reasonable chance of Wolverine showing up.
On top of that, there were dozens of
miniseries, one-shots, and specials. All told,
there were around 26 different Punisher series
or one-shots published between 1990 and 1995,
clocking in with a total of 343 issues and
three book-length original graphic novels. For
comparison, that's how many issues of Amazing
Spider-Man were published from 1963 to 1991.
The strangest one by far,
however, was Punisher Armory,
a ten-issue series written and drawn by Eliot
R. Brown in 1990. Punisher Armory's first
issue promised to reveal "His thoughts! His
feelings! His weapons!", and did exactly that.
There was no plot, just full-page drawings
of guns and other assorted weapons,
captioned with highly detailed reviews
written from Frank Castle's point of view.
Please note that almost all
of these were real guns,
and said reviews often contained Frank's
endorsements for real-life gun manufacturers.
The weirdest thing about Punisher Armory
comes when you try to figure out why it exists
in the world of the comics themselves. If
these are Frank's thoughts about his weapons,
then who is he writing them down for?
"WHY… would you do this?"
Only slightly less bizarre than Punisher Armory
was the franchise's fourth ongoing series,
and the only one that didn't
star Frank Castle: Punisher 2099.
Launched in 1992, the first wave of 2099 books
was focused on cyberpunk versions of Spider-Man,
Doctor Doom, and the Punisher, along
with a new book called Ravage 2099.
While the rest of the line was of varying
quality, Punisher 2099 is worth your time
if you ever find it in a dollar bin somewhere.
Jake Gallows essentially had the same origin as
Frank — family murdered by bad guys, big jacket
with a skull on it, etcetera — but when he found
the original Punisher's old War Journal, he
decided to take up his one-man war. If Frank
was an anti-hero you could understand, Jake was
a full-on fascist with a secret prison under his
house where he kept bad guys until he executed
them by disintegrating them one cell at a time.
He would later become the director of S.H.I.E.L.D.
after Doctor Doom took over the world.
By 1995, the age of Frank holding down three
monthly titles and flooding the market with
spinoffs were over, but to be fair, it wasn't
just him. After the massive speculator-driven
boom in the early '90s that had seen comics like
X-Men #1 selling in the millions, the comics
industry nearly collapsed, with a contraction
that saw Marvel declaring bankruptcy in 1996.
This led the company to sell off the movie
rights to popular characters like Spider-Man
and the X-Men, leaving them with the ones
nobody was really interested in. You know.
Iron Man, Thor, the Avengers. Who would
want to see a movie with those B-listers?
Anyway, after his titles got the axe, Frank was
caught up in a crossover called Over the Edge,
which, among other things, saw him having a mental
breakdown and killing Nick Fury. Fury got better,
but Frank also believed that he'd killed
an innocent family in Central Park,
much like his own family had been killed. That
led him to finally plead guilty for what we can
only assume were several thousand deaths.
He was sentenced to die via electric chair,
only finding out seconds before they
threw the switch that the family had
been killed by Bullseye, who framed Frank
so convincingly that he bought it himself.
It will not surprise you to find that
Frank's execution was a hoax. Instead,
he was broken out by a crime lord who wanted
the Punisher to take over his empire. "Punisher
joins the mob" was an intriguing hook, but the
relaunched Punisher only lasted ten issues.
In the late '90s, Marvel was clawing its way
back from bankruptcy with the time-honored
strategy of throwing whatever they could
against the wall and seeing what stuck.
In 1998, however, the tide began to turn.
That year saw the creation of the Marvel Knights
imprint under artist and editor Joe Quesada,
who handpicked creative teams with
longtime collaborator Jimmy Palmiotti.
The basic idea was to put the spotlight
on "street-level" Marvel characters with a
grittier direction that would hopefully propel
them to stardom, and it worked — so well,
in fact, that Quesada wound up becoming Marvel's
Editor-in-Chief two years later and Chief Creative
Officer in 2010. Looking at the four titles
that launched the line, it's easy to see why.
Christopher Priest's Black
Panther redefined the character,
introducing lasting concepts like the
Dora Milaje and blending the Panther's
cooler-than-Bond world-traveling royal Avenger
status with street-level action. Paul Jenkins and
Jae Lee's Inhumans was the most well-regarded
run on those characters since their creation,
and has kept that status in the decades since.
The flagship book, Daredevil, paired Quesada
with writer and filmmaker Kevin Smith, sparking a
trend of recruiting from Hollywood that continues.
And then there was Punisher by Christopher Golden,
Tom Sniegoski, and the legendary Bernie Wrightson,
which is commonly regarded as the low
point in the character's long history.
The concept they came up with was very
strange, even by Punisher standards:
after killing himself, Frank was resurrected as a
ghost and recruited by angels to hunt down demons,
using magic machine guns that he pulled out of
his magic trenchcoat. The twist was that his
celestial recruitment officer had actually
been his family's guardian angel, who had
been asleep on the job the day they were killed in
Central Park. Unfortunately, the book was a flop,
and a second attempt at "Angel Punisher" that
guest-starred Wolverine didn't improve things.
Two years after the failed experiment of Angel
Punisher, the Marvel Knights line took another
shot at Frank, and this time, it worked so
well that it would become the definitive take
on the character. Fresh from their massively
successful Preacher at DC's Vertigo imprint,
writer Garth Ennis and artist Steve
Dillon took a back-to-basics approach
of pitting Frank against an
over-the-top caricature of the mob.
Dillon and Ennis brought Punisher the same blend
of ultraviolence, grim humor, and surprisingly
deep character work that made Preacher a hit.
It produced what was unquestionably the best
Punisher run of all time up to that point,
influencing virtually every interpretation
of the character across all media for the next
two decades. Ennis would wind up sticking around
as the character's primary writer for the next
eight years, with a few scattered stories since.
In that time, he oversaw the Punisher's
transition from the Marvel Knights line
to the flagship of Marvel MAX. While Marvel
Knights had been more of a gray area, the Punisher
of the MAX years just did not coexist with
characters like Spider-Man and Captain America.
Propelled by his renewed success in the comics,
the Punisher would hit the screen once again in
2004, starring Thomas Jane as Frank Castle and
John Travolta as the villainous mob boss Howard
Saint. This time, the film was influenced by
the Ennis/Dillon run, bringing in characters
like the Russian, a nearly indestructible
assassin played by wrestler Kevin Nash.
Unfortunately, in terms of quality, Punisher
2004 is roughly equal to Punisher '89.
While it has a little of the flavor of the comics,
the movie gilded the lily with some weird choices
that dragged it down. A lot of things that didn't
need explaining were given detailed origins,
like getting his skull logo from a t-shirt his
son bought because it scared him. Frank was also
an undercover FBI agent, making his family's
death a revenge killing rather than the random
violence of the original. Perhaps strangest,
the setting was moved from New York to Tampa.
Despite the movie's flaws, Jane is a
solid choice, and clearly developed
a connection to the character. He
voiced the Punisher in a video game,
and pulled out of a sequel because he
didn't believe in the script. In 2012,
he even made a well-received ten-minute "fan-film"
called Dirty Laundry where he reprised the role.
Even Jon Bernthal, who would go on to play
the Punisher on Netflix, was a big fan.
A third Punisher film, Punisher: War Zone, was
released in 2008 from Academy Award-nominated
director and former world karate champion
Lexi Alexander, starring Ray Stevenson as
Frank Castle. This time, the movie stuck
a little more faithfully to the comics,
pitting the Punisher against
Jigsaw, and bringing in Microchip
as Frank's sidekick. Unfortunately, there
were also some pretty weird choices,
notably in giving Jigsaw a brother, a cannibal
named Loony Bin Jim, adding what was essentially
just Jigsaw-Plus to the movie instead of
just focusing on Frank's most enduring enemy.
The Punisher and Daredevil have
been linked in comics for years.
They're frequently depicted as ideological
opposites, and one of Ennis and Dillon's most
memorable issues involved Frank "explaining"
his methods by chaining Daredevil up
and forcing him to choose between shooting
Frank or letting him kill a murderer.
As a result, it wasn't surprising when Netflix's
lineup of Marvel series expanded to include the
Punisher, who first appeared in Daredevil's second
season before being spun off into his own show.
Despite a fairly positive reception, the
show was canceled — along with all the
other Netflix Marvel shows — in 2019,
in advance of the launch of Disney+.
Check out one of our newest
videos right here! Plus,
even more Looper videos about your
favorite comic characters are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one.